is anyone alive in there general taurian
was defending a group of refugees at the
end
you're the barbarian yes that is
must die
i heard the sound of his screams until
his flesh dissolved to nothing
and only his armor clad skeleton
remained his jaw
unhinged blue mist swirled around his
foe
coalescing into new fish when at last i
cut him down
the phantasmal flesh exploded harmony
spread across my vision until all i
could see was blackness
it gave way to a pain of light that
sapped my strength
it seemed so easy instead i drew upon
the last of my wheel and fought back
color flooded back into my sight the
shadow was right before me
and i drove my spear through it
defend the church repel these
need more time
i like to think the world is safer now
ah we found you
the real why is my because he feeds on
death and with the prime evil gone
humanity has we are descended from
demons and angels
church all the refugees are inside
follow me
accurate bane this is worse than i
feared what is that
a death mate stop her
your soul
why does he want there may be then you
study this
you